[Musique]
quel but poursuit sa transition
énergétique 41 nouveaux bus vont être
alimentés au biométhane attrape les
premiers bus pourraient circuler d'ici
la fin de l'année le centre de
vaccination de mantes-la-jolie va
déménager il fermera le 31 janvier et
devrait ouvrir le 3 février à
magnanville au complexe sportif firmin
riffaud le rappeur kery james et les
footballeur nabil fekir et brianne dabo
ont décidé d'offrir une bourse de 12
mille euros aux titulaires du
baccalauréat qui habite à trappes les
inscriptions sont ouvertes jusqu'au
dimanche 30 janvier à minuit l'acteur
yvelinois sami ou tal ben ali est nommé
aux césars 2022 dans la catégorie du
meilleur espoir masculin pour le film
une histoire d'amour et de désir de
leïla ben bouzid réponse le 25 février
lors de la cérémonie le latmos prépare
le lancement de son second
nanosatellites inspire sats est prévue
en 2023 un an après avoir lancé le
premier il est actuellement en phase
d'assemblage et a été présenté pour la
première fois la sixième édition de la
semaine olympique et paralympique se
déroule jusqu'au 29 janvier à saint
quentin en yvelines avec comme objectif
de faire découvrir les trois sites
olympiques saint quentinois de nombreux
ateliers sportifs sont organisés à cette
occasion
[Musique]